Norway is famous for its extreme climate of
long sunny summer days, long dark winter nights,
and extreme cold.
They are also famous for their welfare state
(like any other nordic country), but perhaps
most of all they are famous for their smoked
salmon!
And it’s not just us who think that - the
fishing industry is one of the most modern
and important in the world...
However, in the last few years, the most significant
element of the Norwegian identity has been
its commitment to the environment, especially
its fight against climate change.
And there is no better place for us to see
this than in their adoption of the electric
car.
You see, Norway has the most developed market
of electric cars in the world.
In Norway, one out of every two of the cars
sold is either electric or hybrid!
But there´s more...
By 2025 (which is basically tomorrow) Norway
expects to stop selling gas or diesel powered
cars.
They only want to sell electric and hybrid
It’s pretty hard to imagine, right?
After more than a 100 years of combustion
engines, it all seems as if it’s about to
come to an end, at least for this country…
Here, electric “car” mania has even reached
their ships.
Two companies are currently developing a project
called the “Tesla of the Sea”.
Its goal is to launch the first autonomous
ship powered by electric batteries.
The first “Yara Birkeland”, the formal
name of the project, is expected to be ready
by the end of 2018.
And this might leave you wondering, well,
what’s Norway´s secret?
How on Earth have they made electric cars
quite so popular?
Are they really so concerned about the environment?
Well, yeah, maybe that is a part of it.
But the majority reason is rather less idealistic…
The key for this electric car boom has everything
to do with the tax incentives that the government
has granted to support this industry.
Look, in Norway, when you need to buy a car,
you can save a fortune in taxes if you choose
and electric vehicle.
For instance, you don't have to pay any VAT
(and in Norway that’s a 25% right off the
bat).
You also don’t pay for the registration
fee or any other additional taxes.
So what’s the result of all of this financially?
Well, according to a recent study, a Tesla
Model S, for instance, would cost around $140,000
if all the taxes gas powered cars have to
pay for were to be paid on it, but thanks
to this tax relief, the price is actually
around $70,000.
50% in savings!
Pretty good, right?
Oh, and then there are the other advantages...
these cars do not have to pay for tolls or
even parking meters.
Further, in Norway, most of the electricity
is hydroelectric, which means it is both cheap
and clean.
As a result for these and other policies,
the government expects to reduce carbon emissions
by 40% in the next few years.
So, now you know this, and also if you consider
that this is one of the countries with the
highest living standards in the world...you
might be thinking...Well, wow, what a great
country!
Even the Norwegian constitution itself is
concerned with the environment.
Consider article 110:
“Every person has a right to an environment
that is conducive to health and to a natural
environment whose productivity and diversity
are maintained.
Natural resources should be managed on the
basis of comprehensive long-term considerations
whereby this right will be safeguarded for
future generations as well” Article 110b
of Norway´s Constitution.
However, as always, not everything can be
sunshine, lollipops and rainbows...
Norway is a wealthy country, with a huge welfare
state.
BUT they do have a small issue…
Or, at least, a problem that makes Greenpeace
really angry:
And that issue is about the oil production
of the country.
But, really, how oil-dependent is Norway?
Well, let’s take a look...
OIL ADDICTS?
If we could take a time machine back to the
beginning of the 20th Century, we would find
Norway with a very basic economy.
All they did was fishing, fishing and more
fishing.
If we travelled forward in time and, even
though things improved significantly, Norway
during the 1960s was in no way included in
the list of the wealthiest countries...
not at all.
In fact, its per capita income was around
half the amount of Switzerland's income.
“In 1960, the standard of living in Norway
was about 30 or 40 percent lower than in Sweden
or in Denmark.
Now the standard of living in Norway is substantially
higher than in those two countries."
Bruno Gerard, an economist at the Norwegian
Business School in Oslo.
So now we must ask, well, what happened?
How did Norway become one of the richest countries
on Earth in so little time?
Well, it all began to change in 1969, the
year when the first oil reserves were found.
And, since then, it’s been a bit of a golden
ear.
The country became one of the world's largest
oil and natural gas suppliers.
And, as you can imagine, this oil revolution
meant tons of money coming in - money that
contributed to building the Norway we know
today.
Today, oil and natural gas are keys of this
country's economy.
In 2016, for instance, almost 40% of exports
and more than a fifth of investment had its
origin in the oil and gas sector.
And, of course, the government gets its share…
Look, depending on the year and the prices
of gas and oil, the income the government
obtains from this industry varies from 1 out
of 4 to 1 out of 6 Euros of the government´s
tax collection.
That is A LOT of money.
And more public income usually means…
more public spending.
“World's Most Generous Welfare State Leaves
20% on the Dole”Yep, that’s right.
To a certain extent, we could say the Norwegian
model of a huge welfare state with public
control of many of the large companies, has
a lot to do with oil.
However, the fall in the prices of this raw
materials has led the government to take a
very controversial measure:
For the first time in 20 years, the government
has granted new exploration licences.
In particular, 10 new licences of oil exploration
in the Barents Sea, in the heart of the Arctic
Circle.
And the truth is, this movement has made Greenpeace
and other environmental organizations really
angry.
Greenpeace has, by the way, taken the government
to court accusing them of violating the Paris
Agreement and also of violating the Norwegian
Constitution itself.
As we already told you, the environment is
well protected in Norwegian law.
But the thing is, Norway´s green commitment
has certain limitations...
“Norway has set out to be a global leader
in climate action, yet continued expansion
of oil and gas production could eclipse the
benefits of Norway’s domestic emission reduction
efforts”.
Peter Erickson, a senior scientist with the
Stockholm Environment Institute.And the reality
is that the world’s largest welfare state
does not come cheap…We, as a country, we
are petroholics [...] we depend so much on
the income from the oil.
Just like alcoholics, we do want to stop,
but we don’t know how.”
Thomas Nilsen, Editor of the Independent Barents
Observer.
But, hey, it is not as if Norway was like
those other countries that only rely on oil.
Absolutely not.
The country is dependent on oil to a certain
extent, but it is not even close to how dependent
Venezuela or Saudi Arabia are.
In Norway, things are very different.
Although the government carries a lot of economic
weight, Norway has tried to be open to business,
and they have tried to use all this oil money
to fund productive activities and to provide
a quality education.
They’ve also been very committed to saving.
THE FUND OF FUNDS
For a country that has made so much money
with the oil industry, Norway is very different
to what we are used to.
Oslo, the capital city, is not taken over
by sky-scrapers, or massive malls, or extravagant
complexes.
In other words, they may have spent a lot
of money, but the key to Norway is, probably,
that they haven't wasted it (as it has happened
in other countries.)
The Norwegian government made the sensible
decision to save a lot of their oil money.
They set up a sovereign wealth fund to invest
the money, and buy assets all around the globe.
And this is the biggest sovereign wealth fund
on Earth.
Not even Saudi Arabia and Kuwait have saved
so much.
Consider this:
“Norway's Sovereign Wealth Fund Hits $1
Trillion” ForbesA.
Trillion.
Dollars.
This is a fortune of around $190,000 per citizen.
Instead of wasting the oil money, they decided
to invest in companies all around the world.
This fund has invested money in more than
9,000 companies in 78 countries.
Some of these companies are really famous:
Apple, Nestlé, Shell or Alphabet (better
known as Google).
Yes, indeed, we could say that the Norwegians
own part of YouTube!
And you know what?
One of their targets is to eventually replace
their oil income with income from these investments.
These investments they all produce profit
(as you can probably imagine)...
Well, since the creation of the Norwegian
Sovereign Wealth Fund, the average annual
return has been around 5.7%.
So, if this level of return was to be kept
the same, Norway would get an average of $50
billion in profit.
That’s equivalent to 25% of their public
spending.
Sound good, right?
On top of that we must add the income the
government gets from oil and local companies…
Companies that, despite being state-owned,
work with market criteria.
So, well, you might be thinking that Norway
has nothing to worry about, right?
Well, wait just a second.
The welfare level seems to have a solid base,
but the government is determined to achieve
economic diversification, in order to have
a more competitive economy, so they ultimately
get rid off their dependency on oil.
THE REFORMS
Since 1927, the centre-left Labour Party has
been the most popular in general elections.
But in Norway, absolute majorities are not
common.
In 2013, a coalition of centre-right wing
parties like the Progress Party (famous for
its radical position on immigration) managed
to put Erna Solberg in office.
She is known as the Norwegian version of Angela
Merkel.
Recently, in the elections of 11th September
2017, this coalition was re-elected.
The intention of the government is to get
some distance from what has been known as
the Norwegian mode.
The government wants to improve the competitiveness
of the country by reducing taxes, especially
for companies (both public and private).
But, they also intend to keep developing the
oil industry.
Anyway, if they are sure about something in
Norway, it is that innovation and development
are the best ways to obtain high standards
of living and improve the environment.
So, now it is your turn.
Do you think Norway is an example to be followed
in the management of natural resources?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
Don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And
as always, thanks for watching!